ouais la grandeur des bâtiments ok d'accord
nous avons cette bonne altitude ouais excellent
ouais ouais c'est une bonne chose gardez-
le angle blanc comme cette entreprise pour
guerrier je veux dire comme des ombres s'il y a
un moyen mais je ne pense pas que ce soit vraiment
ça n'a pas d'importance  Je ne vous pense pas pour
le moment,
je pense qu'ils vont vous donner des coudes
parce que certains de ces bâtiments adjacents
en sélectionnant un peu copieux ouais
30 être un endroit où aller
nouveau représentant de l'entreprise 504
qui vous ici le jour où j'étais
Bermudes ah ce qui s'était passé ouais j'étais
censé voler j'aurais passé
des chemins entre le pont George Washington
de la Statue de la Liberté une évasion sûre d'
accord c'est bien continue donc nous
avons le patron de l'homme blanc donc Sean sait que nous
ne sommes pas un  un peu de bêta
prenons quelque chose juste un peu plus de cet
ensemble de gars ils ont eu une photo sur le
grand angle nous avons encore 20 30
secondes à Rome ouais juste un peu plus d'
événement si Peter le pilote va bien si nous
pouvions  passe bien aussi
il va falloir  être un 1500 ce que nous
faisons ici d'accord eh bien j'ai eu des cerfs-volants
abattus merci beaucoup manquer
le Holland Tunnel encore cent pieds
nous allons être nous donnons ce
mètre de côté bon ouais ouais nous allons dire bien
le bon départ  au-dessus ouais j'ai attrapé
notre newark ne comptez pas 40 pour tango Delta
Je vais y aller maintenant mais j'essaie de
tenir une tour êtes-vous cet hélicoptère
40 pour tango Delta après 403 tango Delta
ni vous souciez de tango Delta  son terrain
héroïne cuisses aime bosser dans ce quartier
1500 en poste quelques minutes pour
tango Delta Squad 03 36 je suis mort 03 3 6 à
ça passons par la fin de trois
quatre elle ride se termine encore ici viens
souviens toi Jean echo Delta plus rouge
contacté au sud du Holland Tunnel de
1200 avec notre espace n'a pas derrière juste
sur 1000 a frappé excusez-moi un tuyau euh
pas le droit de faire ça va tango descendre
pour signaler une rotation regardant sur cette
scène avec pour dépenser 1500 travail
homme les trois  -point ici j'avais 14 ici
vient
je veux-tu veux-tu  pour aller de l'
ouest de la voie facile aller vers le nord s out le
conducteur j'aimerais faire tous les 30 ou plus de
confort ou de fils sur un pont je réponds
mais nous pourrions bouillir au-dessus de l'eau ces
travaux êtes-vous à 35 ou 36 vous avez dit
qu'elle pense clairement ou quoi que ce soit et que nous
ayons quand vous venez au bord de la route pas de
pont racine, nous pouvons aller manger ici et
vous aider parce qu'ils ont le trafic aérien,
il n'y aura aucun moyen de monter pour Victor que nous faisons
avec la Statue de la Liberté Je connais un
deuxième aéroport d'accord arrêtez d'enregistrer c'est
un long chemin pour ça juste un plan où nous
devrions être sur si ça d'accord nous pouvons le
faire fermer l'orichalque pour déchirer que le
camping est au sud des gouverneurs mes hommes
atlantiques travaillent en arrière pour s'étendre pour se souvenir
de tango Delta  produire demandé
chercher une Amanda actuellement trois sud mais
de bridgnorth facile sur 14 autres je les
garderai sur le panneau du New Jersey qui l'
apprécie il a 34 partages radar
contacter le prêtre du pont Verrazano
effacer les numéros maintenus par l'état du navigateur
une altitude  jusqu'à 300
alors fatiguez-vous alors nous resterons du
côté de Jersey merci monsieur et Travis venez en
orbite juste au-dessus de Ground Zero un
hélicoptère ouais c'est vrai pour
nous presser d'aller aussi près
ok c'est un port sous ça ouais
c'est  une récolte tout droit ici
avec eux Roger jargon dans le trafic
laissant essentiellement tout leur insigne pour
faire du commercial troisième heure kappa sig 36 en
bateau sur alpha dr.  strick va réparer le
promoteur Kara attention pour un hélicoptère
sur l'horloge à 1500 un client juste en
dessous de moi juste oui je sais que ce sont les
gouverneurs sur ce qui ressemble à la typographie du
centre-ville c'est comme aller
là-bas juste à côté de s'attache au
pont verrazano yeahhh monsieur  formidable
Trumbo dit contact radar 1210 le
plus grand lecteur de décharge de l'Iowa eh bien c'était
personne n'a vu un parc ou alors et tellement bon
de penser que c'est une bonne vitesse
rappelez-vous 606 du trafic de l'hôtel à
midi deux milles en direction du sud 800
types Nikita assez pour regarder
tous  malade va réparer notre sans
trafic supplémentaire pendant que la boîte ta
bouche maintenant Pat 1205 inconnu est 68 69 prend
Pablo Seltzer à gauche 10 degrés cherche
le trafic pour être le Holland Tunnel
juste moi pour 1100 dis oui degrés
qui paie le numéro trois pour l'air marin
trafic ou racheter que votre
hélicoptère à une heure deux milles Roger nous avons sur
le sondeur 36 yeux fixés sur le
trafic de l'hôtel n'est plus un facteur la passivité il
avait 1 100 vous  vouloir obligation contacter le
public en direct sont 12 6.05 2605 nous avons eu
que les pilotes ont été construits par eux
Merci Irma au tango Delta finances si vous avez
manqué une triche vers le nord côté New Jersey
1400 Je ne fais pas ma chance de
peser
paroles ala copter 944 promesse
numéro 34  c trafic aérien une heure vous
bouche vers le sud 1000 enfants pour le
garder en dessous ou s'inscrire ayant un détecteur de poisson
il est super 200 personnes OB et c'est juste à
côté de mon nez oui IM juste à côté de votre
droite maintenant 1100 je viens de voir un hélicoptère
Tucker Baynes Tim  jamais de relation pour un
simple contact laguardia Tara 1270 nous faisons
ce pont coulissant 1 2 615 avant le
résultat de partage que nous venons de faire ouais et
Peter top 10 sur les cheveux de la femme de Roméo Rogers
bouché donc vous obtenez deux valeurs de congélateur
de lumière nous voulons Romeo x-  ray tourner à
gauche 10 degrés sud-ouest je vais
vous faire contourner le trafic dans 11 que le
montant restant correct se produise ou vous-même de
votre patch de cours de perche qui vous a mis
un moment pour le bureau même un ou un
personnage abou  t 7 à l'ouest
comme station de sortie au-dessus de la ville à 11 heures
il pleuvra et à l'ouest de votre
table d'approches 14 villes à travers
maintenir VFR hors de la maison de Louis environ 7
30 0 75 n 3007 nous y voilà un déchiré par la guerre
sera  électrique ce n'est pas le bon virage
maintenant recherchez un trafic Embraer à cinq
milles du niveau final deux mille descendu
pour votre cap 444 Brava Roger qui a
maintenu via pour moins de 800
passez à deux milles ou à la maison de Milan au
sud-est du pont de Bayonne vous
avez un  mile et demi, nous continuerons,
monsieur, gardez un œil sur le problème
numéro six Bravo alpha contactez LaGuardia
Tower 12 6.05
à pour futaba en tant qu'ex parte remplacez
alpha Bravo partiellement Turtles
ouais de cette façon, vous pouvez voir le sol 0
correctement
ce qui est  ou que tout va
être prêt bonne eau qui plonge dans le
transfert en ce moment alors maintenant vos fleurs
bébé ce qu'il a fait beaucoup de changement de fréquence
approuvé pour une ligne plate supplémentaire vous
ne pouvez pas couper un peu pendant que l'on mûrit
ils choisissent c'est e  e peste un
peu méfiant je suis le drapeau de la famille vers le bas ils
laissent un comme ça c'est parfait ouais mais d'
accord qu'est-ce qui se passe à droite
ouais ils ont mis sumthin sumthin facile d'
obtenir une bonne image presque au hasard
conclusion et Robin je déteste tout ça par les
gens  là-bas et en marchant autour de lui,
c'est un drapeau, les meuniers de riz sont partis maintenant, ouais,
continuez à vous taire jusqu'à la fin,
cela va obliger le valet à le
garder, à le garder sur un sein ou à vous lever
tôt ouais, d'accord, le propriétaire couvre à
nouveau la haine statique
vous pouvez vendre leur propre médecin 130 d'accord
merci quel est ce mot balayez balayez
balayez vers la droite